made in China made in India made in
Guatemala made in wherever Oh election
time when the loss of factory jobs in
America suddenly becomes a favorite
talking point among politicians we are
gonna bring our jobs back into this
country for the first since 2001 in
America we have lost almost 60,000
factories millions of decent-paying jobs
what could you only buy products made in
the US even if you wanted to and is it
worth it a lot of things that used to be
made in the US aren't anymore if I were
to take everything I own that's not made
here what would I have left not much
okay can I just have my couch back just
no we're done it's not surprising the US
has lost five million factory jobs since
2000 and 97 percent of all clothing sold
in the US is imported from overseas at
least American Apparel is that going for
it even if it is a little mmm but as a
consumer it's not always easy to find
out where things are from one thing you
won't find made in the US a cell phone
or basically any other electronic new
hobby coloring buying american-made
won't leave you totally deprived of
everything you need
well why ever bother well manufacturing
jobs are important because they're
well-paying jobs with benefits that
don't require a college degree making
them a path to the middle class for many
Americans and when it comes out sourcing
we're not just talking jobs we're
sending our pollution overseas too as
factories move to countries with fewer
environmental regulations and then
there's the environmental cost of all
that extra fuel used to ship goods
halfway across the globe labor in other
countries is often cheaper but that
sometimes comes at the expense of
workers rights sown by the nimble
fingers of a ten year old of course
there's no guarantee that buying u.s.
made mean
buying from companies that are ethically
or politically compatible with your
views
nothing like giving my money to the Koch
brothers and global trade means labels
don't tell the whole story
a shirt made in Bangladesh may be made
of US grown cotton and an appliance
assembled in the US may use foreign made
parts economists say that moving
production of popular items back to the
US would raise prices for consumers wait
how much step but a study from the
Alliance of American manufacturing found
that if Americans spent just 64 dollars
a year on US made goods they would
create 200,000 jobs there's also the
argument that it's not about buying
locally it's about free trade but the US
has been importing more than an exports
for decades and even if it returns US
manufacturing probably won't look like
it did in the 1970s one thing is clear
if consumers really are dedicated to
buying US made goods they're gonna have
to change their ways and what's it gonna
take to make that happen